okay so in this video we're going to
talk about the pentose phosphate pathway
in the actual reactions of the pathway
including both the oxidative and non
oxidative phases so we'll start here
with glucose 6-phosphate diverting off
from the glycolytic pathway I'm going to
show it up in its straight form straight
chain form okay so we start off with 106
phosphate here and you'll notice off to
the right I have this little 3 X bracket
out here and so what that means that you
can imagine that we're starting off with
3 glucose 6-phosphate just for the sake
of calculations and like tracking
stoichiometry for the the whole process
okay so it's kind of keep that in mind
and I'll be sure to remind you as we go
along but so we're starting off with a
glucose 6-phosphate and the first step
is catalyzed by glucose-6-phosphate
dehydrogenase so we're going to actually
convert glucose 6-phosphate into six
phospho Buchan o delta lactone so that
name is kind of weird but just so the
heads up this carbon up here carbon
number one a glucose 6-phosphate that
whole thing going to come off eventually
as a carbon dioxide and the beginning of
that is first oxidizing it here by
making this cyclic ester and that's
actually a little lactone is a lactone
is simply an estimate as part of a ring
a cyclic ester and it's Delta
specifically because the carbonyl carbon
starts there and as you go along the
first carbon attached to the carbonyl
carbon is the alpha carbon then we got
beta gamma and then Delta so Delta is
the actual carbon number five here which
actually connects here to make that
cyclic ester okay maybe more detail than
was necessary but I figured I mention it
and of course the phosphates on carbon
number six now since that car that
carbon there is oxidized something else
is reduced and that what is reduced it's
the nadp+ turn being turned into NADPH
and we can see here that NADPH is
involved with glutathione here I don't
want to get too crazy into these details
here but this is kind of a little bit
about how NADPH plays a role as an
antioxidant so you see free radicals out
here eventually those are reactive
oxygen
they eventually kind of make their way
into hydrogen peroxide and hydrogen
peroxide is an oxidant and can damage
cells so instead of going through and
damaging our cells and tissues
glutathione in the reduced form takes
the hit gets oxidized into the oxidized
form of glutathione that's catalyzed by
going to file peroxidase which is an
enzyme that uses selenium as a cofactor
the peroxide is now harmless water or at
least much less harmful water and then
we have NADPH go back and regenerate
reduced glutathione using the
glutathione reductase enzyme okay we'll
talk more about that in its own video
but just wanted to show that here also
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase is a
regulated enzyme and NADPH being a
product feeds back negatively on this
enzyme so a high ratio NADPH to nadp+
goes through and inhibits the enzymes
activity right the product inhibits it
and then the ratio is important so low a
low ratio of NADPH native e+ activate
this so there's too much nadp+ so more
energy p+ activates the enzyme more
NADPH inhibits the enzyme next step six
phospho GU kono Delta lactone is
converted into six phosphor gluconate so
we also mentioned earlier the pathway
that's called the fossil gluconate
pathway disguise the reason why so
what's going on there basically at this
point the same x six phosphate Wakana
lacks in hydrolase or also known as
block kinase takes that lactone and
basically hydrolyzes that ester to get
this carboxyl group ready to be ousted
as a carbon dioxide okay um and that's
what happens in this step here
so that 6-phosphate Buchan 8 is going to
be oxidized to ribulose 5-phosphate oru
5p and so that that group there comes
that carbon dioxide comes off here
carboxyl group comes off as a carbon
dioxide and we oxidize this carbon here
carbon number 3 here which becomes
carbon number 2 here to make ribulose
5-phosphate okay
and in that process
since we're oxidizing this molecule it's
something else is being reduced any DV +
is being reduced NADPH and it also NADPH
can be used in reductive biosynthesis to
convert precursors and monomers into
polymers and other biomolecules right so
that's a reductive and apple ism
happening there so that marks the end of
the oxidative phase and those steps are
irreversible now I mentioned that this
would happen three times right so we
started off with three glucose
6-phosphate switch our three six carbon
molecules three of those carbons came
off as carbon dioxide because one for
each each of those six carbon molecules
we started with so now you have three
five carbon molecules re-review lowest
five phosphates okay so that was all the
oxidative phase and now we're entering
the non oxidative face
you